as promised he is the two-time national
champion head coach of clemson football
which uh is in its 12th year under his
head coaching
leadership um as a uh for the entire
season
took over in the middle of the 0.8
season at any rate his name is dabo
swinney here on the rich housing show
how are you coach
i'm great rich good to be with you good
to be here yeah you bet so what is a day
of a coach like yourself with a national
signing period
next week when you're taking on notre
dame
for uh the acc championship what is your
day filled with
dabo
yeah well it's uh it'll be a little
different this year the year's past
you know it's been it's been during our
bowl prep uh when we've had this day so
you know we just kind of had to balance
practice and getting the
signing day procedure done and uh it's
been it's been fun it's been good
this year is really different because
obviously the season is pushed back we
we would have been done a week ago or so
and
um but but we obviously are playing all
the way through december the 19th
now uh so we've got a a little different
but we did
we are fortunate that we had a we have
an open date this week
so it won't be a typical game week uh
we'll be way ahead as far as our normal
uh
game plan you know procedure and process
but we'll uh you know typically we have
a lot of people in the building a lot of
things going on on sign day we're not
we can't do any of that so it'll be
pretty simple we're going to make it fun
uh for our for our signees and we'll
probably start about 11 o'clock in the
morning and
involve each coach and the whole thing
will probably take about an hour
uh so uh it's it's going to be really
good in fact we just kind of went over
our our procedure uh this morning in a
staff meeting it'll be
it'll be fun uh but i am thankful we
have the open date
uh so that it it it won't be uh uh
any more crazier than it needs to be so
is it like a virtual run of show is what
you're saying or
to to announce who's yeah a virtual app
yep virtual run a show we'll have um
you know each coach involved it'll all
be you know we'll have a
a a commentator that's kind of
you know emceeing the whole thing and
we'll have video of all the signees and
comments on them
uh from myself and the coaches and and
do some kind of unique things some neat
things to really highlight these guys
and make it a special day for
for everybody who was again i just
mentioned you're in your your 12th full
season
as uh head coach there at clemson who
was the recruit that helped you
i guess put your foot in the ground and
start going in the direction where we're
seeing you
uh year in and year out now is there a
recruit
one guy who yeah well i would say
ironically the the first one uh i wasn't
the head coach but i did recruit him and
that was cj spiller
so i i recruited cj and then
his his uh junior year
uh in the middle of the season we were
three and three that's when i became the
interim coach
and um and so you know ironically
i would have to say him and again i
personally recruited and so
uh he was a huge part no question of me
getting this job because you know he
he came back you know we finished strong
that team
went four and two to finish up the
season and that gave me an opportunity
to get the job and then cj
chose to come back to play for me his
senior year he could have gone on and
gone pro and
and we won let us start first acc
championship game we didn't win but we
won our first division title and
and got a taste of it in 09 and uh
you know which is which is which was
awesome so i would have to say him and
then and then my first recruiting class
we signed 12 guys i called him the dandy
dozen and those 12 uh because i
only had a few weeks to go recruit and
uh but i had a young man named taj boyd
yes who could have really gone most
anywhere and taj boyd came in here and
really helped lay the foundation for the
program that we enjoy now and led us to
our first acc championship in 20 years
led us our first bcs win beating ohio
state in 2013 beating lsu and
in the peach bowl in 12 and it really
built a
a great foundation for desean to come in
here trevor etc
so i would have to say spiller taj boy
and then grady jarrett on the defensive
side
if i had to pick one guy uh man grady
jarrett
was a foundational piece uh to this
program yeah both swinney clemson
football here
on the rich eisen show let's go to the
here and now so you're taking on notre
dame for the second time
this year and um how would you i
had uh brian kelly on this week i'll ask
you the same exact question
how would you um talk to the
i guess front load if you will to the
committee that if you lose this game
that uh you should still be in in the
top four
when there are others that may not have
played the same competition or even the
same
number of games coach
yeah i mean it's a it's a really obvious
that's a tough question to answer
in in my position because you know um i
mean we feel like we're definitely one
of the best four teams in the country
and there
there's nothing that's going to happen
in that game next week for clemson or
notre dame
that's going to change that in my
opinion you know and that's based on
data uh and i i don't think that
you know what's almost like uh you know
you
you've got to have 120 hours to get a
business degree and
and but yet you know these people over
here only need 60 hours to get a
business degree
uh i think you know anytime you step in
in between the lines in the game of
football there's a lot that can happen
um a lot i mean heck we we
in 2017 we lost to a three win or four
win syracuse team and still went to the
playoffs
you know so anything can happen guys can
get hurt
uh there's a lot and so i think the fact
that we're going to have 11 games
you know as well as the sec teams i mean
you look at florida and texas a m and
alabama i mean
these teams are gonna have 11 games in
this year uh it's incredible
and um you know i think
the the big ten i think had the same
opportunity
and they chose not to play and i think
the only reason they ended up playing
is is because of the leadership of the
sec and acc and the big 12
and have demonstrated that we could do
it and do it in a safe way and it's been
a
it's been an unbelievably challenging
season that's for sure but
but i think that you know
the committee's going to have some some
tough tough
tough questions to answer and things
like that regardless of what they do
and obviously as coaches we don't
control any of that stuff
um you know so you know i i do think
that uh
our team has has has played incredibly
well
you know we had a double overtime loss
at the number two team in the country
now notre dame
it was a great team and uh in an
unbelievable game
and again no matter what happens for
notre dame or clemson
uh nothing changes in that in my mind as
far as
uh both of these teams being in the top
four
so again and uh i asked this of coach
kelly as well and he did to say the same
thing i'm just the coach
um i i had to point out that just like
you
you are influential you're an influencer
so
you would have a problem with not making
it obviously
but you would have a problem even if you
did make it maybe that that a team that
played half the number of games would
make it
would you have an issue with that coach
i wouldn't have an issue with it because
again it's not my it's not my
uh my position to have an issue with it
my position is to coach my team
regardless of whoever
and and you hate it for i just think
that there has to be some type of
standard and uh you know i just think it
would be if i was
on a committee it would be hard for me
to leave out
a uh 10-1
texas a m or a uh or a
11-game florida team
um you know over a team that's played
six games that would be hard for me
if i was on the committee but i'm not on
the committee
uh so doesn't really matter it doesn't
mean they're not a great team
and could win the whole thing i just
think that there has to be
um you know i just think from a big
picture standpoint
i would lean toward rewarding the teams
that have
have been all in so uh and and
because it's been an incredible
challenge no doubt it's been
it's been a unique season as you you
know
um had first-hand experience
uh by the way i think i mistakenly
received your christmas card from
florida state
coach swinney um you know it's been
a wild campaign so what about the idea
um if and i know i'm spitting in the
wind but to me
you know coastal carolina i'd love to
see him get a crack uh against you
you know or alabama uh i'd love to see
eight teams i'd love to use this season
in the same way that major league
baseball recognized that they had to
expand their playoffs in the nba and the
nhl had to reconfigure the way in which
teams qualified for their playoffs um
and just say this is a different year
let's get eight teams in would you
would you take issue with that or would
you be in favor with
of something like that yeah well i think
i think
i think that gets back into again now
you're going to ask some teams to play
14
15 games and some teams to play you know
seven
eight nine games and and i just i don't
think i think
it's that's a real challenge uh because
the totality of the season
is it's it's a different team after 11
games than after
five or six games uh in every regard
you know mentally physically you name it
and um
so i mean hey whatever uh you know i i
think
the word for 2020 is flexibility and uh
you know focus on what you control and
that's that's what we've tried to do
around here so
you know what we didn't even know our
schedule we didn't even know who we're
opening up with until mid-august
uh so you know we're just excited to
play
and uh you know but i i know this i
wouldn't want to extend
our season uh these yeah we're next
week's 20 weeks for us
uh 20. uh you know
typically we've gone about 13 14 weeks
but we started at the beginning of
august and uh
he didn't play till you know
mid-september
and and now we're all the way to
december the 19th but we've been going
since
we've been going since the end of july
when they allowed us to start doing
their walkthroughs
started practicing in the first of
august so
i certainly wouldn't want to extend the
season um
but you know i don't think that that
would be right for
all these teams like i said that have
been going for a long long time
i don't think that's fair to the kids a
few more minutes left with dabo swinney
clemson football uh right here on the
rich eisen show
coach i don't normally uh wave my fandom
uh and
and uh uh uh i guess start preface a
question
but this is very important to me as a
jet fan how's trevor
how's he doing
[Laughter]
is he okay trevor is great yeah is he
awesome how's he looking he's awesome
yeah he's never been better he's pretty
special
yeah he's pretty stressed hair is
perfect
yeah likes uh likes the grind
likes the grittiness of football okay
he's a
he's he's pretty special um is he um
at all thinking about the future do you
guys have a conversation
about what he's thinking oh he's had a
lot of conversations well
yeah he's thinking about the future he's
thinking about uh december the 19th
i'm looking over the steering wheel sir
i look over the steering wheel sir
i look over the steering wheel yeah he
is going to graduate he's going to
graduate on december the 17th
okay uh at one o'clock uh p.m
so okay i'm excited about that for him
as well and he's getting married
next spring where's he registered
where's he registered
where's he registered coach because i'd
love to i'd love to send something
yeah i don't i don't know do you still
do that go register
i don't know you're going to get him
you're going to get him some um what's
that stuff called
the fine china yeah no a gravy boat do
people still get that
he might need a cat he might need a
gravy boat i don't know
certainly to fill it candle stick or
something
yeah you know he needs a saucer and a
coffee cup
that's what i'm thinking about just and
and uh uh you know because he is a
fine piece of china himself coach and
there's a lot of conversation at the
next level that he's looking at what's
happening with a
particular winless team and how dreadful
they look
and would be thinking about not
going to them if they draft him would
you say that there's any
thing to such a conversation
i have we've not had any conversation
about that but
you know regardless of who don't you
have to be bad did you get the number
one pick isn't that kind of
isn't that the way it works
that's the deal that's the way it works
so i mean regardless
you know i don't think he's going to go
to a super bowl team coming off a super
bowl where it's not like he can
out out of high school he was able to
pick to come to clemson
you know pick up the shot from where
desean watson left off he doesn't really
get that opportunity
uh regardless of what year he goes out
he
kind of that's just the way it is but
i'll tell you this
regardless of where he goes he's gonna
win uh
because he's a winner that's what he
does and uh
he he's he's gonna be just fine
uh whoever gets him will will
quickly realize just how special he is
well i don't think you
need to admonish any uh talent
evaluators like your last
uh quarterback who has proven to look a
lot like michael jordan and cleats
um that you don't need to admonish them
to dare to put a second grade uh
uh tag on this kid um and uh
i mean it's it's there's a lot of talk
um
that he wouldn't want to come that just
doesn't sound like him i've never met
him but i've heard about him i've heard
in your voice it just doesn't sound like
somebody would just um
not want to take on the challenge this
is the
this is the most humble uh
easy to be around kid you'll ever meet
in your life
he he i always tell people i know he
looks like hollywood
he's the most least hollywood guy you
ever
want to meet he is so low maintenance
blue collar
uh same guy every day incredible
focus work ethic love of preparation
i mean he's desean watson's everything
you love about desean watson he's just
six six
and a bigger arm but he can run he's got
those same intangibles
just a wonderful young man got it all
together
and uh you know he's he's not afraid of
any challenge i can tell you that so
he's either
not when it comes to this game of
football he loves it so he's lebron in
cleats then right
what'd you say i don't know i don't know
you know that that gives him that's a
little different you know he's
successful you know
i like lebron but i'm an mj i'm an mj
guy okay okay
some personal stuff
well i went personal with the jets so i
look again i know you got to win a game
against notre dame
and then you have some other games that
you're hoping to play after that just
take care of them
tell them uh i'm thinking of them um and
uh and to to to be well tell them to be
looking for that coffee cup and saucer
that you're gonna
send you know off his register yes bed
bath and beyond
and he's the beyond he puts the beyond
in bed bath and beyond okay
speaking on behalf of all new yorkers
you take care of it speaking of
you know i always have gone for
thanksgiving yes i've always been at my
mom's and my brothers
who eat with them my wife had to cook
our first thanksgiving her first
thanksgiving full meal because we had to
all be at my house okay
and i think it's the first time i've
ever eaten on our
fine china that we got you know when we
got married 20
going on 27 years ago i think it's the
first time i've ever seen it i even know
we had it
uh but but we got we got it
right i mean i'm sure it cost people
money and you know we registered for
that stuff
yes many many many years now uh so
thank you to all the people who gave us
our nice
uh plates and saucers and i saw them for
the first time
yes uh thanksgiving day it might be like
algebra you know you you know you're
gonna
you might not know when you need it but
sometimes you you need that sort of math
in your head you know at some point
it'll come and like to find china yeah
x plus x equals 2x i think that's you
got it
you got it i think you got it enjoy
checking on the x y's and z's for
for your game and we appreciate the time
as always coach thank you
all the best same to you that's it dabo
swinney you bet same new davos swinney
clemson head football coach right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here